hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with round 11 and it's Magnus Carlsen
versus the an opponent so it's like
Peter Spindler said I think it was a
yesterday or maybe two days ago in the
livestream you never know which nipple
will show up in a game will be nipple
who can just you know destroy everyone
or will it be nipple who who blunders a
piece in the opening so here again very
exciting as a nipple is one of the few
people that has a positive score against
Magnus Carlsen in classical time format
however this is rapid so now let's see
what happens and it's well a game like
this you haven't seen in a while
so Magnus again opens with E for and
nipple goes for c5 are most likely
preparing the night off we have Knight
to f3 d6 and now d4 we have characters
characters Knight to f6 and now instead
of going Knight to c3 and allowing a6
Magnus again goes for his the deny der
of denial variation so called with
Bishop to c4 the same he played against
Maxime offering this efore pawn and we
already explained what happens if e d4
pawn is captured in the Maxime game but
if you don't remember we will repeat it
because here nipple actually goes for
the pawns when he nipple grabs the pawn
and of course he checked at the
variation because Magnus already played
it against Maxime also in this
tournament and the Magnus continues with
Queen to h5 okay you're attacking the f7
pawn neppo defends it and now like we
mentioned in the in the mcawesome vs
Maxime game you have to go Bishop to b5
check here and then after black blocks
with whatever let's say Bishop here only
then do you capture on e6 and then the
game continues let's say if you go Queen
t7 denied the c7 check is an idea but it
all pretty much trades down nothing
serious is happening 97 check King here
now you cannot capture because of the
Knights the g3 check will win you the
Queen and well just show it here just
Knight to g3 check and you cannot block
with the Queen because the knight also
control z2 so you just lose the Queen
here so what you would have to go for is
Knight back to the 5 attack the Queen
black would force a trade and after
captures captures we would have let's
say F 3 goes here and sees Bishop c4 and
the game continues material is equal and
you just you know can't
you playing with Queens traded off
however Magnus didn't go for Bishop to
b5 check he instead immediately captured
on e6 and this is just incredible as now
this is what this is just blunders a
piece because neppo captures it and this
position has been read before but the
player with the black pieces played
queen t7 here however Neto captures with
the bishop and it is as of move 7 that
we have come a completely new game and
as the title suggests white is
completely lost here as he's down a
piece so well you can recapture of
course Bishop captures this is what
Magnus played and now of course the the
F pawn is pinned but Queen to e7 by nape
oh and again you face the same problems
if you move the bishop Nigeria check
pics of the Queen you cannot defend and
if you try something like castles -
maybe undermine it later it still
doesn't work because of Queen captures
here rook e1 threatening e f3 but it
doesn't matter just d5 you defend it and
after f3 you have better up the c5 check
King moves and now it's just well mate
for black so that doesn't work
so instead Magnus played Bishop
characters on f7 and we have Queen
captures on f7 and the Queen back to e2
now trying to recapture the piece but
Queen back to e7 so what now we have
castles by Magnus and now never just
continues with Knight to f6 he wants to
trade Queens as he is upper piece so how
will Magnus continue this well ok
necklace can get stone the center so
maybe you can still play Bishop to e3
and just Knight the c6 Nippo makes way
to Castle queenside we have Knight to c3
and d5 now by nipple we have Queen to f3
and now with a double attack on the
phone here and nipple just castles while
also defending the d5 pawn rook F e1
now preparing some nasty discoveries and
never just move the Queen Queen d7
we have Knight the b5 going for the h7
pawn but the just a 6 and here Magnus
says I'm down a piece there's pretty
much no point in well I do resign here
or I try try to go all in
so he goes a 4 hope I hope so of course
for characters captures and then maybe
he will have some maybe some ideas with
the rook there but nipple of course
doesn't allow the attack Queen to g4 and
now he forces the Queen
Magnus has to trade Queens and now
Bishop to b6 attacking the rook here but
Knepper says okay now I'm more than
happy to grab the night with a
character's eight captures in the now
just the night the b8 getting the knight
out of harm's way
Magnus captures the rook but then just
keen captors and e8 and here we have a
position where nipple has three pieces
for the rook which is just insane of
course black is much better here and the
Carson is extremely low on time
yeah I forgot to mention is before
actually sacrificing on e6 Magnus spent
like seven minutes so I have no idea
what happened there but yeah h3 in the
now tonight back to f6 we have looked
the a7 going after the b7 pawn never
just defensive Kings is seven rook the
e6 and now Bishop the c5 just developing
preparing to bring the rook into the
game we have B sex with check trying to
get the rook over to the seventh rank
and opposes okay Bishop captures rook e7
check and King to d6 now Carlson is able
to capture on b7 but Knight B to d7 now
and here okay cause and characters and
g7 but nipple plays King to c6 and it
was in this position and move 28 that
Magnus cross and resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you do you're losing the rook
so you would have to probably give up
the exchange here captures captures and
then is just unplayable it's two nights
against the rook and Carson knows that
there is no point in continuing this so
what happened here I have no idea we're
gonna probably find out after after the
match one calls and maybe they're shed
some light on this but yeah yeah after
east six Bishop e5 is a must if you want
to continue it plating this aggressive
variation where you sacrifice a pawn not
allowing the night off but yeah Carson
spent a lot of time here and then he
just captures here which is incredibly
interesting since this is his novelty
which he prepared for this tournament to
deny the night off you know when he
plays against muxing for sherrilyn graph
and a young Pony she here so really
really a really awesome stuff now I'm
sure MVL is now thinking man I should
have captured that night it's it's crazy
stuff but yeah now that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it the
is the first time I think Magnus lost
the game like this he did he didn't lose
one game in seven moves it was against
the Grisha but it was a it was a
chess960 game Fisher random game where
Carson forgot that you could actually
Castle you know the weird way like you
do in chess960 but yeah a really crazy
stuff you know they put the Jedi Master
with it with his mind tricks so I do
hope you enjoy that I would like to
thank Christian spraying Kevin Clarke
Henry's parents gone and saw the wall in
the Lakatos a year ago for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes the check
if Magnus can get back into this match
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day